Welcome back after the break. So, let us continue our discussion over supervised machine learning
and as I mentioned just before going to break, we are now going to talk about another classifier
it is called support vector machine or SVM. So, today only you learnt about linear classifiers
right like where you would like to differentiate between one class versus another class. So,
let us just assume that this solid dots here they denote class 1 and the hollow dots here
they denote class minus 1. Now, how can you differentiate them? Now, if you look at any
linear classifiers like the ones which you have studied today, they would try to draw
a decision boundary which separates these two classes. So, something like this. So, all
the models will try to come up with this boundary which will the boundary means what? That this
kind of distinguishes or this kind of separates the one class with another class. Now, in
this case the solid class with a hollow class plus 1 and minus 1 correct and typically it
takes some form like this like where w's are the weights you learn x is the x is the
feature set and b is often called a bias or this is just an additional thing additional
weight similar to w. Now, so when we apply such a model one decision
boundary can be like this which I have drawn you may come up with a little better decision
boundary like this someone can come up with another decision boundary like this or this.
Now, see so whenever you are coming up with this decision boundaries they are all separating
the two classes quite well right this is also separating the classes this is also separating
the classes this is separating the classes in fact the one which I draw that also separates
the classes. The question however is if you have so many different type of linear classifiers
which one to choose like which one would be the best classifier? Now, to answer this question
actually the whole concept of support vector machine came. So, the idea was that I would
like to pick a classifier linear classifier which will have the largest surrounding margin.
Now, what is margin? Margin is defined as the width that the boundary could be increased
by before hitting a data point. So, if you see here that this particular point is like
belonging to this yellow zone. So, the yellow margin is not very good in this case because
what we are saying is that the margin should be such that there is no other data point
in this margin like this shaded region should not have any other data point. Now, rather
than this if you are so in this example the margin is like very small, but if your classifier
was like this then you tend to get a much better margin see.
So, this is the whole idea of SVM or linear SVM is we would like to get the linear classifier
boundary which will provide us the maximum margin as possible. So, maximum margin linear
classifier is the linear classifier which has the maximum margin. Now, the data points
like this or this or this which actually fall within the margin or which fall at the boundary
of the margin are called support vectors because support vectors are those data points that
the margin actually pushes up against. So, this support vectors because they are called
support vectors from this the name support vector machine actually came from. So, they
are essentially talking about these data points these are the support vectors which determine
the margin of a particular linear classifier.
Now, why we would like to go with maximum margin classifier? So, first of all that if
you look at it intuitively this feels the safest option that if you have a maximum
margin classifier the chance of error is low. So, why if let us say this is your classification
boundary that this is my classification boundary if a new data point is falling here I can
immediately classify this data point to be plus 1 because I know that I have enough margin
for error. While if you are looking at a classifier which is like this now if a point is lying
here I cannot say whether this was really plus 1 or this is actually plus minus 1 because
if you see the location of this new point this is much closer to the other data points
in plus minus 1 than the data points in plus 1. So, margin if the margin is maximized a
maximum margin classifier tends to have a lot of leeway where you can avoid making error
in the classification.
So, again like on the same topic or on the same point if we have made a small error in
the location of the boundary if you are going with a maximum margin classifier this gives
us the least chance of causing a misclassification. The model is immune to removal of any non-support
vector. So, it does not matter whether you are removing this data points or removing
some data points here because they are so further from the classification boundary that
they do not impact your eventual performance. And generally empirically it has been observed
that SVM works very well.
Now, let us try to represent this idea little mathematically although we will not go through
the entire proof because we do not have enough time for the full theoretical exploration,
but I will just try to still give you a little flavor so that if you want you can also check
out the proof through other sources. So, essentially if you when you consider a classifier boundary
like this, so we kind of consider a zone where there are a lot of class 1 or 1 particular
class data points. Similarly, on the other side there are zones where you have a lot
of let us say negative data points. So, just think of this like this that you have crosses
here, you have ticks here, you are coming with a decision boundary like this, so this
is your decision boundary. So, this is the zone for let us say plus 1 class, this is
a zone for minus 1 class. Now, you can actually think that I am going to draw another kind
of line or a pen which separates the plus 1 zone from the actual classification boundary.
Similarly, if I can draw another negative pen which separates the zone of like negative
zone from the decision boundary. So, this is what is called a plus pen, this is what
is called a minus pen and this is of course the classification boundary which we are talking
about. Now, let us try to kind of derive this a little mathematically, so for that let us
have a simple mathematical background. So, the length of a vector, so you know the vector
is essentially vector has a direction like vector is a collection of like a collection
of numbers, but which also has a direction, because otherwise you will have scalar values
which does not have direction which are only numbers.
Now, the length of a vector is called a norm, so in this case let us say the vector is something
like W1, W2, W3, Wn the norm of W is denoted as this symbol like this is a symbol of norm
and if you see you are essentially taking a square root after summing up all the individual
data points within it and the norm can also be denoted by if you take the transpose of
the vector and multiply that, so you get the norm square of this. So, this is again a property
of a norm and in general as I mentioned that it has direction the unit vector on the particular
direction of W is given by the vector divided by it is norm.
And in general when we multiply two vectors especially when you take the dot product of
two vectors it leads to a scalar value. So, essentially when W2 transpose W we are taking
this actually leads to square this leads to a scalar value, so in this case the norm is
essentially a scalar value and since so this you can think of this as if that you are taking
the vector you are dividing it by the norm of the length of the vector and that way you
are getting the direction of the vector through I mean essentially as I mentioned that the
difference between scalar and vector quantity is that vectors have direction where scalars
do not have and this is the way to know the distance of direction of a vector.
Now why all this is important, now in our SVM example, so this is our this is one zone
let us say this is our negative zone, this is our positive zone, this is our plus plane
this is our minus plane. Now and this is our weight vector W, so the direction of this
weight vector will be as we saw this. This is the margin of a classifier, so this is
the decision boundary and the margin is essentially the distance between the plus plane and the
minus plane. Now what is important here is you can actually represent the plus plane
as Wt that means like this is my linear classification algorithm which is putting like where you
are looking at the x vector which is the vector which is the feature vector of a particular
data point you are multiplying that by the weight vector and of course like you have
one additional constant but this value is going to be 1 because we are talking about
the plus plane here for the minus plane we are taking the same value and taking it to
be minus 1 and the decision boundary is essentially Wt transpose x plus p is equal to 0.
Now so for y when it is plus 1 we get this that because the plus plane is Wt transpose
x plus b is equal to 1 any data point which is beyond the plus plane will have value greater
than is equal to 1. For negative class since the minus plane has the equation W transpose
x plus b is equal to minus 1, so any value here will have either minus 1 or less. So
in this side it will be less in this side it will be greater than 1.
So if you combine everything if you just multiply the yi now you may wonder how do I get yi
because yi is the outcome this we are talking about only the training data not about the
test data okay. So for this we actually know the y values and the x values. So we apply
that and we understand that this is going to be greater than is equal to 1 because when
yi is minus 1 you are also getting this value to be minus 1. So when you multiply this minus
and minus it becomes a plus, this value is plus this value is plus again when you are
multiplying two positive quantities this will be plus.
So effectively you get you cannot compress this two and you get this one single equation.
Now one proof which I am not giving but you can check this online tutorial to understand
the proof that the margin of these two classifiers given this is the positive pen and this is
the negative pen is given by 2 by the norm of the weight vector w. This is a little complex
proof it requires a lot of steps so I am skipping them for now but for now let us just assume
that this is true that the margin of the classifier is 2 by the norm of w where w is the weight
vector. So in that case essentially the whole finding the large margin classification or
classifier boils down to this particular optimization problem.
So we want to maximize the boundary m so this is equivalent to minimize the minimize 1 by
m which is similar to half of norm square. And we know that the decision boundary needs
to satisfy all the data points correctly and the data points will have an equation like
this. This is something we saw for a positive so if my positive range is here or sorry let
us say this is the negative range this is the positive range. So for the positive range
you get y i to be positive and then the entire thing to be positive so it is greater than
equal to 1 for the negative 1 y i is negative and the entire thing is negative so you again
get the multiplication to be more than 1. Now this becomes a constrained optimization
problem where you would like to minimize the value essentially that is same as maximizing
the margin and you want to follow the constraint on the value of each individual data point
in your training data. Now why you are doing all this because effectively you would like
to know the w. So think about it what is the variable here. The variable here is essentially
w and b x i is something which you know from the training data y i is something which again
you know from the training data. So these are your feature set this is your output level
you are trying to get only w and such a w so that like it also maximizes the margin of
the classifier. Now it turns out that this constrained optimization problem is also not
very easy problem to solve. So in fact to solve this there are a lot of mathematical trick
people apply where they convert this this problem like this constrained optimization
problem which is also called a primal problem to a dual problem.
Now I am just going to show you the dual problem here. So essentially this particular alpha
values are called Lagrange multipliers and this dual problem is also called a Lagrangian
dual problem where all this alpha values are greater than is equal to 0 such that like
the sum of alpha i y i is equal to 0. Then for a training data you know y i you know
y j for the same training data i and j you know their feature set. So once you apply
all this and you try solving this problem like with respect to like so essentially here
what is happening is that you are trying to determine the value of alpha provided to all
the different training data which you have. So essentially all the training data here
with its own levels will have a specific alpha like alpha i is for the ith training level
and then you apply this particular constrained optimization problem you solve this using
some quadratic problem solver like Cplex is one tool which is often used after that you
actually apply all the alpha value y i and x i values to get back the weight.
So note where we started we wanted to compute the decision boundary and the decision boundary
would be given by the weight value of W what we ended up getting we ended up getting the
value of alpha which is again called a Lagrange multiplier and this multiplier value which
we are getting effectively to allow us to get back the W which we are looking for.
So essentially our goal was to get the weight vector W through all this process we are trying
to get back the weight vector W. Now in SVM there is a very interesting thing which happens.
So every alpha is essentially as I mentioned they are connected to each individual data
points in the training data. Now many of the alphas will tend to be just 0 and effectively
the weight vector W it becomes a linear combination of a very small number of data points and
in fact these data points where the alpha was not 0 this small number of data points
are called the support vectors. So from this the name support vector machine came the beauty
of this is that the decision boundary essentially gets determined only by the support vector.
So the W instead of going over the all the values of alpha y i and x i if you just have
S support vectors so you can simply take the support vector and their corresponding x and
y values and you can get back the weight vector that is it.
So if we look at it this pictorially so you see that for almost all the non support vector
which does not fall in the decision boundary the alpha values are 0 only the ones which
fall on the I mean basically fall on either the positive plane or the negative plane they
will have some alpha value which is non zero and you just have to consider them to determine
the value of W and that way for any new test data point Z you can compute so now I know
W I kind of know for the test data what is going to be the Z be again I know from the
earlier equation I just simply apply this and by applying this we can get the value
of the current test data point. So just to summarize what we have done so far.
So we actually in SVM we get a list of training data alright then we say that we are going
to apply a linear classifier classification algorithm on top of this. Now up to this all
is fine you can apply any form of like linear classification algorithm to come up with a
decision boundary. The problem is that with different values hyper parameter values or
the choice of the actual linear classification algorithm you may come up with a lot of decision
boundaries. So all the decision boundaries can in fact differentiate between the positive
class and the negative class or any such classes very well.
Problems are happening when we want to determine which classifier to choose because every classifier
is working fine and you cannot just say that I am just going to randomly choose one classifier
and just going to go with it. So in SVM the goal is to pick a linear classifier where
the classifier boundary has a margin of error and this is the margin so essentially a margin
consist of the space around the decision boundary where like you are not hitting another data
point either on the positive side or on the negative side.
So this whole region is called a margin and our goal in SVM is to maximize the margin alright.
Now I understand that some of you may not have got the mathematical details because I went
through that very fast and I also did not explain all the steps due to lack of time.
But I would encourage you to go and look up the tutorial link which I have shared over
on the slide and also you can also search on YouTube or in general like any online tutorial
where you will get the understanding of the entire optimization process how that optimization
function is created and how exactly it is solved.
The bottom line is that even if we skip the theoretical foundation the beauty of SVM is
that effectively for the classification boundary or the decision boundary which we were computing
where we wanted to keep the margin to be the highest.
It just turns out that the weight vector for that particular decision boundary can be determined
just by looking at the support vectors for which the alpha like which we computed in
that optimization process they are non-zero and in reality in any kind of classification
problem you see that only a handful of data points in the training data they will contribute
or they will become a support vector.
So the whole idea of KNN was that during the test time you would like to compute which
are my nearest data points look at the labels and then determine the level of the current
test data point by looking at what the closest neighbors are saying and I told you that this
is a very expensive process because we are doing almost all the operation during the
test time.
In case of SVM since we are dealing with only a few support vectors so we can actually look
at support vector calculation and support vector base calculations to be a very tiny
scaled down version of the time of computation we do we tend to do for KNN alright.
So SVM tends to run faster than KNN and often times since there is a very nice theoretical
background around it this tends to also provide a very good answer.
Now so far we talked about only binary classification.
Now in case of SVM unlike naive base here we cannot really compare among multiple classes.
So the approach which SVM takes is like one versus all strategy.
So if you are trying to make a multi-class classification with n classes you take one
class as the one like you want to determine this class one versus all the rest.
So you try to determine whether this particular point belongs to class one or any of the other
points and if it does not belong to class one then you go to the next round where you
try to differentiate between class two and any other data points kind of.
So that way eventually one of the iterations you will get the correct class level.
So this strategy is called one versus all strategy.
We did not look at another aspect so so far we have been talking about only linearly like
linear classifiers but support vector machine can also work with non-linear like non-linear
classification problems.
So I will just give you one example.
So a linear classifier problem means that when your classes are like this you can simply
come up with a decision boundary which can differentiate these two classes.
But when you are you have a class like this right so your decision boundary cannot be
a line.
So it cannot be linear.
So in this case let us say we looked at a circular decision boundary.
So these are cases where it is a non-linear boundary which we are dealing with.
Now so far the support vector machines we have talked about they are they work only
with linear classification boundaries but there is something called a kernel trick like
where kernel functions are used which allows the SVM to deal with non like non-linearly
separable classes.
Compared to some other methods like let us say naive base SVM is still time and space
consuming but it is much better compared to let us say KNM.
And we have to store all the support vectors so rather than a simple model we have to store
all the support vectors and often time that creates or that adds to the space complexity.
So with that this actually ends today's discussion on supervised machine learning where we have
covered the cover three different classification models, naive base classification, support
vector machine and KNM neighbor.
So now it is time to take up a few questions.
So why different method in neighborhood is being used any practical example.
So I guess your question is related to the K nearest neighbor algorithm and you wanted
to know why different distance metric is used.
So look different distance metric is often used depending on the particular application
scenario so and Euclidean distance is something which we often use like which is a very simple
measure if you can place a particular if you can so let us say that you are trying to determine
the distance between two data points in a in a in a map or let us say this you just
want to determine the ideal distance between two places.
So you look at a particular place A, you look at a particular place B, you look at the lat
long of this place, you look at the lat long of the other place and you try to determine
the distance between the two by looking at the Euclidean distance between the lat long.
So when we say lat long essentially it is a two dimensional space right like you look
at both the longitude and the latitude of both points and then you just compute the
distance between that but that only gives you the ideal distance like if you can travel
by let us say air this is the amount of travel you will have to do.
But in reality you are often constrained by the physical road.
So if there is no road which takes you from place A to place B this area distance is meaningless.
So the Euclidean distance which we computed it does not actually tell the real situation
better.
So in such cases let us just assume that you live in a city where the city is like grids
okay.
So grid means that okay there is a point here then a road just goes from this point to this
point then then there is one road like this then another road like this.
So where the city is designed in right like a grid where you have parallel roads like
this and parallel localization like both horizontally and vertically okay.
So if you have a scenario like this and in reality such a kind of a nice grid like road
network exist in Manhattan district in New York.
So there if you want to compute distance between two different data points you will
have to follow the road.
So you will have to let us say go up or go down to catch the next intersection and then
you will have to take right or left to reach the other place.
So this kind of setup where you are just following the road and go to from one point to another
point you can capture this in one distance metric called Manhattan distance or 11 distance.
As the name suggests but because it can originated from this Manhattan district block or grid
like road structure it is called Manhattan distance.
So depending on the example, depending on the application scenario like whether you
are trying to determine the distance between a driver or a passenger you will have to consider
the road network.
But at the same time if you are just trying to place let us say some like loud speaker
you can actually look at the aerial distance there the road network does not matter.
So depending on the application you pick a different distance metric and the similar
thing is applied in case of classification like K nearest neighbor classification as well.
So how to know which classifier is best suited for our requirements this is a very nice question
and this is why the whole idea of cross-validation come into play as I mentioned.
So you have a training data point, you do not know which classification algorithm to
apply correct.
So the best idea is that you apply multiple classification algorithms you look at the training
data you I mean again so you split the training data into an actual training data and the
validation data you train based on the actual training data you apply them on the validation
data.
Now the beauty of validation data is that for the validation data you have both the
features that means you have the X value and you also know the level Y value because this
is a part of the original training data set.
So based on this level switch you have you can compute how many of your predictions were
correct or wrong.
So that way you can compute what is called an accuracy that how many times your prediction
was correct and you apply different classifier models using this actual training data, apply
them on the validation data compute the accuracy and finally pick the model or pick the classifier
which gives you the best accuracy over that validation set.
So this is how we can utilize or pick the classifier to work in a real world scenario.
Next question, how are the data points falling in the margin in SVM?
So the way margin is defined is that we are going to margin is the area around the decision
boundary which we can expand until we hit a point.
So this is why like always the margin ends with hitting a data point in either side of
the decision boundary and these data points which fall along the margin they are called
the support vectors.
And as I showed that to compute like a level for a test data point essentially this support
vectors are used and the data I mean the predicted value is computed.
Again like I think this question came up earlier as well so the books I think some suggestion
of the books will provide it not during the current session so you can check I think like
will provide it offline like some good reference books where you can look at this topics.
There are generally good some like good tutorials online tutorials which are also available
but often time it is better to follow some book where you can read them in more detail.
We will provide some reference book links later offline.
Thanks a lot for attending the lecture today.
We will meet again next week where we will continue talking about classification algorithms
where we will cover decision tree and the ensemble methods like random forest.
Thanks, have a very nice weekend.
Thank you sir.